Chris Cuomo who you know he got kicked
off CNN in disgrace he's got his a new
gig now uh here he is admitting and this
Chris is a Democrat obviously right
admitting that fetterman struggled and
wondering a bit about his health voters
I think saw things that will definitely
change the state of this race it's not
his fault but lieutenant governor
fetterman struggled
um and again I'm not faulting him for it
I don't think his preparation was great
but he clearly is dealing with health
issues that affect his ability to
process and his ability to speak now in
politics you absolutely have to be able
to
articulate right and argue and convince
so how you say it matters but the basic
issue is uh is the brain function intact
do you have the ideas can you form the
thoughts
how do you break down those two
different ideas so in the brain
cognition and language are separated but
there's so much interaction between them
so it's hard to say whether his memory
his executive function his ability to
make decisions based on the information
that he receives is impaired
okay so what's interesting about this
and there's a reason I showed you a
Chris Cuomo clip look I obviously I'm
not a big fan of the guy I think he was
a terrible anchor on CNN who got most
things wrong ran cover for his brother
who was governor of New York obviously
he's a Democrat activist but I want to
show you that occasionally these guys
sometimes something is so obvious right
it is so in your face that they have to
acknowledge it so again it's like he's
right about the communication part even
if I disagree with all the fetterman's
ideas which I do if he could articulate
those ideas clearly if he could say
these are the things that I believe in
clearly and calmly explain them then we
could have an honest debate of the
issues right this reminded me a little
bit in a way of the the Florida debate
that I was at two days ago because on
one hand you had and again I my cards
are on the table obviously I like
Governor DeSantis but he can clearly lay
out what his policies are what he has
done what he believes and then you have
someone on the other side who will
literally say anything nothing to do
with being with the truth so that's one
version of it and another version of it
is you have Dr Oz who clearly and we're
going to show you a clip a couple clips
from Dr Oz in a moment you have Dr Oz
who clearly and calmly lays out his
beliefs and his policies and then you
have a guy who simply cannot do that
that is a an asymmetry that is just very
weird where you know flashback 10 years
ago you'd have a Republican and a
Democrat they could both communicate you
at a sense of what they believed for the
most part and they could go at it now
we're having these crazy debates where
either people can't communicate or they
lie about everything or they tell you
that they didn't do the thing that you
know that they did et cetera Etc